Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the Vietnam War in the morning. It sounds like the rest is history. It is indeed the rest is history, and our theme today is the Vietnam War. Dominic. Hello, Tom. A field of particular interest to you, I think.
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周的额外剧集、无广告收听体验、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。这就是早晨的越南战争。听起来就像“历史的余味”。确实是“历史的余味”，我们今天的主题是越南战争。多米尼克。你好，汤姆。我想这是一个你特别感兴趣的领域。
Yes, I'm sure listeners will be thrilled to hear that this is the sort of the subject of my PhD. So my PhD was on a very little known American politician called Eugene McCarthy, who ran for president in 1968 against the Vietnam War. He thought it was a bad idea. And he basically toppled Lyndon Johnson, who was the sort of democratic incumbent over the issue of the war. And so, you know, I spent, I wasted three years reading about the anti-war movement and writing this sort of unread PhD. But not wasted, because now you can entertain and inform our listeners. Exactly. The depth of your scholarship. Exactly. I knew it would be worth it. I knew one day, after having spent a year in an archive in Minneapolis, or rather in
是的，我相信听众们会很高兴听到，这正是我的博士研究课题。我的博士论文研究的是一位鲜为人知的美国政治家尤金·麦卡锡，他在1968年反对越南战争，竞选总统。他认为那是个糟糕的主意。他基本上因为战争问题推翻了当时民主党的在任总统林登·约翰逊。所以，你知道，我花了，我浪费了三年时间阅读关于反战运动的资料，并写了这篇没人读的博士论文。但也不算浪费，因为现在你可以娱乐并告知我们的听众了。没错。你学术研究的深度。没错。我知道这是值得的。我知道有一天，在明尼阿波利斯的档案馆里待了一年之后，或者更确切地说是在
St. Paul, the twin city of Minneapolis, I knew that one day I would get a 45-minute podcast out of this. Oh, listeners, how lucky you are. But Dominic, it would be fair to say that, of course, the Vietnam War is not just about the reactions to the Vietnam War in America. There is actually fighting going on there is in Indochina yes do we have a world beating expert we well I thought we needed somebody at the absolute top of the game um I thought of an old friend of mine who um is absolutely steeped in the Vietnam War and has devoted much of his career to it he sadly can't
圣保罗，明尼阿波利斯的双子城，我知道有一天我会从中整理出一期45分钟的播客。哦，听众们，你们真幸运。但多米尼克，公平地说，当然，越南战争不仅仅是关于美国对越南战争的反应。实际上，印度支那确实正在发生战斗，是的。我们有一位世界顶级的专家吗？嗯，我想我们需要一位绝对顶尖的高手，嗯，我想到了我的一位老朋友，他嗯，对越南战争有着极深的研究，并将他职业生涯的大部分时间都奉献给了它，遗憾的是他不能
make it so um we've we've So we've got Professor Andrew Preston from Cambridge, who's another ex-acquaintance of mine, soon to be former friend once he's done this podcast. Andrew, welcome to the show. Thanks, Dom. It's great to be here. I remember our PhD days together really well. I don't remember you spending a year in the archive. I do remember you going off to Minnesota and spending a year there. I remember you spending a year playing PlayStation and drinking a lot of beer and watching a lot of football. So those are my memories. This is precisely the manly sort of activities that our listeners will expect to be hearing about.
成行，所以嗯，我们有来自剑桥大学的安德鲁·普雷斯顿教授，他也是我的另一位旧识，等他做完这期播客，很快就会变成前朋友了。安德鲁，欢迎来到节目。谢谢，多姆。很高兴来到这里。我清楚地记得我们一起读博的日子。我不记得你在档案馆里待了一年。我确实记得你去明尼苏达待了一年。我记得你花了一年时间玩PlayStation、喝很多啤酒、看很多足球赛。这就是我的记忆。这正是我们的听众期待听到的那种充满男子气概的活动。
Andrew, if Dominic had to go to Minnesota, did you go to Vietnam at all? I didn't go to Vietnam. No, I went to Boston, where the JFK Library is, and Austin, Texas, where the LBJ Library is, and Washington, D.C. But I did go to Vietnam, but not as part of that research. whose knowledge of the Vietnam War is basically, as you could tell from the introduction, where I even misquoted Apocalypse Now, whose knowledge of the war is basically refracted through Hollywood. Could you just give us a kind of sense of how the war began, how it evolved and how it ended? Sure. Yeah. And how many days do we have? This is a challenge for you. In about three minutes? Right. Huge question. I think I can do that. So the French had colonized Indochina, Indochina being Vietnam, Cambodia, and Laos. They did that over a 30 or 40 year period in
安德鲁，如果多米尼克不得不去明尼苏达，你有没有去过越南？我没去过越南。不，我去了波士顿，那里有肯尼迪图书馆，还有德克萨斯州的奥斯汀，那里有林登·约翰逊图书馆，还有华盛顿特区。但我确实去过越南，但不是作为那项研究的一部分。他的越南战争知识基本上，正如你从介绍中听到的那样，我甚至引用错了《现代启示录》，他的战争知识基本上是通过好莱坞折射出来的。你能简单给我们讲讲战争是如何开始、如何演变以及如何结束的吗？当然。可以。我们有多少时间？这对你来说是个挑战。大约三分钟？好。巨大的问题。我想我能做到。所以法国人殖民了印度支那，印度支那即越南、柬埔寨和老挝。他们在
the 19th century. And then World War II, the French empire was basically shattered. And during that period between the late 19th century and World War II, there was an anti-colonial movement fighting for Vietnamese independence. So World War II sort of shatters French power. But because of the Cold War, the US supports the French reimposing their colonial rule. So there's what we call the first Indochina War happened from 1946 to 1954 between the French and trying to impose some kind of colonial rule, some kind of new rule. And the Viet Minh, communists who were also nationalists. And that war ended in 1954 with a famous battle, Dien Bien Phu, which is this incredible story. And a lot of books have been written about it. And instead of just sort of cutting their losses, the US decides because
19世纪的30或40年间完成了这一过程。然后是第二次世界大战，法兰西帝国基本上破碎了。在19世纪末到二战之间的那段时间里，有一个争取越南独立的抗殖民运动。所以二战在某种程度上粉碎了法国的权力。但由于冷战，美国支持法国重新强加其殖民统治。所以发生了我们所说的第一次印度支那战争，从1946年持续到1954年，发生在法国试图强加某种殖民统治、某种新统治与越盟之间，越盟是既是民族主义者也是共产主义者。那场战争在1954年以一场著名的战役——奠边府战役结束，这是一个不可思议的故事。很多书都写过它。而美国并没有选择止损，而是因为
of the Cold War, because of a misreading of what was going on in Vietnam and also the Cold War, they decide in their infinite wisdom to basically take over from where the French left off, to split the country in half and like Korea was divided, like Germany was divided, and create an independent non-communist country, a new country in South Vietnam. And that would be where the free world was. And then the commies could have the North. And of course, the Viet Minh and the Vietnamese nationalists and communists, they don't stand for that. And so they start undermining and fighting the South Vietnamese government the US has set up. And that leads to the big American war in the 1960s. And that ends
冷战，因为对越南局势的误读以及冷战的原因，他们以无穷的智慧决定基本上接替法国留下的烂摊子，将国家一分为二，就像朝鲜被分裂、德国被分裂一样，并在南越建立一个独立的非共产主义国家，一个新的国家。那将是自由世界所在的地方。然后共产党人可以拥有北方。当然，越盟和越南的民族主义者及共产主义者，他们不会接受这一点。于是他们开始破坏并打击美国建立的南越政府。这导致了1960年代美国的大规模战争。而那场战争结束于
in the 1970s. In 1973, u.s um withdraws they made those same mistakes that the french had made they made the same mistakes the japanese had made in world war ii in not being able to hold this country uh against its people's will and so that's the famous scene of uh embassy staff being evacuated on helicopters that's two years later isn't it yeah that's in april 75 so you see the U.S. withdraws in 73. And then like a lot of things about Vietnam, things that we assume are true, that photo, that really famous photo. I always ask my students, what photographs, what are the five most famous photographs or images you think of of the war? That's one they always mention. That was actually on the top on the roof of the CIA station in Saigon, not of the embassy. It's a small detail, but it sort
1970年代。1973年，美国撤军，他们犯了法国人犯过的同样错误，他们犯了日本人二战时犯过的同样错误，即无法违背人民的意愿控制这个国家。所以这就是那个著名的场景，大使馆工作人员在直升机上撤离，那是两年后，对吧？是的，那是75年4月，所以你看美国在73年撤军。然后就像关于越南的很多事情一样，我们认为真实的事情，那张照片，那张非常著名的照片。我总是问我的学生，你们认为关于这场战争最著名的五张照片或图像是什么？那是他们总是提到的。那实际上是在西贡中情局站的屋顶上，而不是大使馆。这是一个小细节，但它在某种程度上
of is very indicative of how just so much of what we think about the war just actually is slightly not true. Well, I reckon that thing of the five most famous photos, I mean, that might be quite a good way of exploring what's going on in the war. What do you think, Dominic? Yeah, I mean, well, tell us about some of these, what about all these misconceptions? I find that interesting as well. So what are the big misconceptions of the war that you're, I mean, what do people, if there's one thing people think
非常能说明我们对战争的很多看法其实稍微有点不真实。嗯，我觉得关于那五张最著名照片的事情，我的意思是，这可能是一个探索战争中正在发生什么的好方法。你觉得呢，多米尼克？是的，我的意思是，嗯，告诉我们一些这些，关于所有这些误解怎么样？我也觉得这很有趣。那么关于战争的重大误解是什么，我的意思是，如果人们认为有一件事
about the Vietnam War that's not right, what would you say it was? Well, I like how you dodged that question. What are the images that come to mind? Well, the images seems a weird thing to me on a podcast, Tom. But everyone will know them. That's the point. They're iconic. I mean, I would immediately say the photo of the girl.
关于越南战争是不对的，你会说是什么？嗯，我喜欢你回避那个问题的方式。脑海中浮现的图像是什么？嗯，在播客上谈论图像对我来说似乎很奇怪，汤姆。但每个人都会知道它们。这就是重点。它们是标志性的。我的意思是，我会立即说那个女孩的照片。
Exactly. With the napalm bomb. Let's talk about that because that is fascinating. That's the one that immediately comes to my mind. Absolutely. That's that. And then I'll give one away. Sorry, Don, this is probably the one you were going to say.
没错。带着凝固汽油弹的那个。让我们谈谈那个，因为那太迷人了。那是我脑海中立刻浮现的一张。绝对是那个。然后我会说出一个。抱歉，多姆，这可能就是你要说的那个。
But the monk who self-immolates, who burns himself in protest in 1963, just sitting still and he's on fire in protest at what's going on. That's another super famous photo that's on album covers and T-shirts and whatnot. But the photo you're talking about of Kim Phuc, this girl named Kim Phuc, who's running towards the camera, a photographer named Nick Ute, who was with AP, I think, the Associated Press, is so iconic. And it really captures the pain and suffering of the war. This gets sort of links to something that Dom asked me about misconceptions. Everyone thinks that that is sort of speaks to the horror of the American war, which it does in large part, because the reason the war was on was because of American policy. But by the time that photo was taken, most of the American soldiers had gone. This is in the early 70s. And the troops that are standing behind her and she's running towards the camera, her back is
但那个自焚的僧侣，在1963年抗议时自焚，只是静静地坐着，他在抗议正在发生的事情时着火了。那是另一张超级著名的照片，出现在专辑封面和T恤上等等。但你提到的那个叫金福的女孩的照片，那个女孩金福，她正跑向镜头，一位名叫尼克·乌特的摄影师，我想他是美联社的，太标志性了。它真正捕捉到了战争的痛苦和苦难。这在某种程度上与多姆问我的关于误解的问题联系在一起。每个人都认为这在某种程度上说明了美国战争的恐怖，确实在很大程度上是这样，因为战争之所以发生是因为美国的政策。但当那张照片拍摄时，大多数美国士兵已经离开了。这是在70年代初。而站在她身后、她正跑向镜头的那些部队，她的背部
literally on fire because it's covered in napalm that's burning and she can't get off. That's the thing about napalm. Just once it sticks, it sticks and it just keeps burning. So she's running towards the camera, the poor little girl, and she's naked. And the soldiers behind her, everyone assumes they're American soldiers, but they're South Vietnamese soldiers. And the plane that had dropped that napalm was a South Vietnamese plane. And so one of the things that we forget about is this civil war dimension, this intra-Vietnamese dimension of the war, that it really was a Vietnamese civil war that the US kind of walks into and then walks away from. There's a tendency, right, with all this, with so many of these Cold War stories or
确实着火了，因为它覆盖着正在燃烧的凝固汽油弹，她无法摆脱。这就是凝固汽油弹的特点。一旦粘上，它就粘住了，并且会一直燃烧。所以那个可怜的小女孩正跑向镜头，而且她是赤裸的。她身后的士兵，每个人都以为他们是美国士兵，但他们是南越士兵。而投下那枚凝固汽油弹的飞机是一架南越飞机。所以我们忘记的一件事是这场战争的内战维度，这场战争的越南内部维度，它确实是一场越南内战，美国某种程度上走进去，然后又走开了。有一种倾向，对吧，对于所有这些，对于这么多关于冷战的故事或
stories about American so-called imperialism, that the other people don't get agency, right? I mean, they probably would have. Am I right in thinking there would have been a war in Vietnam, whether the Americans were involved or not, that the Vietnamese would have fought one another? Yeah, for sure. Without question. Absolutely. And for a long time, the historians kind of ignored that.
关于所谓的美国帝国主义的故事，其他人没有代理权，对吧？我的意思是，他们可能本来就会。我这样想对吗，无论美国是否参与，越南都会发生战争，越南人会互相残杀？是的，肯定的。毫无疑问。绝对是。而且很长一段时间里，历史学家们有点忽视了这一点。
I mean, they would write about the Vietnam War, but there would be nothing about the Vietnamese. That's changed in the last 20 years, thankfully. So there are a lot of historians, unlike myself, who speak and read Vietnamese, who have given a lot of attention, not just to the communist side, but to the kind of forgotten side of the war, the South Vietnamese, the South Vietnamese government, the people, the army.
我的意思是，他们会写关于越南战争的文章，但关于越南人却只字未提。幸运的是，过去20年里这种情况改变了。所以有很多历史学家，不像我，他们会说和读越南语，他们给予了极大的关注，不仅是共产主义一方，还有战争中被遗忘的一方，南越人，南越政府，人民，军队。
And I mean, now it's kind of, you can't really write the history of the war without talking about the North and South Vietnamese and making them a big part of the story. But Dominic, you said so-called American imperialism in your best Daily Mail. Woke bashing mood. But it is. I mean, it is imperialism, isn't it? Well, I mean, they're going...
我的意思是，现在，你如果不谈论北越和南越人，并让他们成为故事的重要组成部分，你就真的写不出这场战争的历史。但多米尼克，你用你最好的《每日邮报》抨击觉醒派的情绪说了所谓的美国帝国主义。但它确实是。我的意思是，这是帝国主义，不是吗？嗯，我的意思是，他们正在……
So just looking at the beginning of it, we've got a question from Mark Taylor. How much of the blame in this goes on the French? Oh, I mean, let's always blame the French. I.e. for not giving Vietnam independence post 1945 and how much blame goes to the US for not putting their foot down when they had the opportunity.
所以看看它的开始，我们有一个来自马克·泰勒的问题。这其中有多少责任归咎于法国？哦，我的意思是，让我们总是责怪法国。即，因为在1945年后没有给予越南独立，以及有多少责任归咎于美国，因为他们在有机会时没有坚定立场。
So the French are clearly imperialist. I mean, there's no question about that. No question. The Americans are kind of secretly backing the French in their war, right? I mean, they're advisors at Dien Bien Phu, I think. Let me just jump in here, Tom, before it goes to Andrew. Obviously, the French are imperialists.
所以法国人显然是帝国主义者。我的意思是，毫无疑问。毫无疑问。美国人在某种程度上秘密支持法国人的战争，对吧？我的意思是，我想他们在奠边府有顾问。让我在这里插一句，汤姆，在转给安德鲁之前。显然，法国人是帝国主义者。
The French have a sense of the glory of France, of the French Empire, and so on. But the Americans, it's slightly different because, of course, the Americans in the 1940s see themselves as anti-imperialist. So Roosevelt is talking about tearing down European colonial empires. And actually, this is a good cue for Andrew, because I have read his PhD in his book. So I know that I think the first line, isn't it, or something like this, the Vietnam War was above all an episode in the Cold War. So you think the Americans don't see themselves as imperialists, but they see themselves as fighting to, I mean, they genuinely see themselves as fighting to uphold democracy, right? Yeah, Tom just said it. It's anti-imperial
法国人有一种法兰西荣耀感，法兰西帝国感等等。但美国人，情况略有不同，因为当然，1940年代的美国人视自己为反帝国主义者。所以罗斯福谈论的是拆除欧洲殖民帝国。实际上，这对安德鲁来说是一个很好的提示，因为我读过他的博士论文和他的书。所以我知道我想第一行，不是吗，或者类似这样的，越南战争首先是冷战中的一个插曲。所以你认为美国人不把自己看作帝国主义者，但他们认为自己是在为，我的意思是，他们真诚地认为自己是在为维护民主而战，对吧？是的，汤姆刚才说了。这是毫无疑问的反帝国
imperialism without question. Yeah, the Americans themselves didn't see themselves as imperialists. I mean, you wouldn't, right? They're just trying to do good. They're trying to spread freedom. They're trying to beat back communism. Why would anyone want communism? The French in this period, in 1945, 1946, even they don't see themselves as imperialists, even though they clearly are imperialists. But, you know, the Vietnamese aren't ready for independence yet. Why would anyone want to turn their back on the glories of France and so on and so forth? And the French also after World War II, they really need this, right? They really need to, they feel that they need to kind of recover some of this glory that they've clearly lost in a lot of the
主义。是的，美国人自己并不把自己看作帝国主义者。我的意思是，你不会，对吧？他们只是想做好事。他们试图传播自由。他们试图击退共产主义。为什么会有人想要共产主义？这一时期的法国人，在1945年、1946年，甚至他们也不把自己看作帝国主义者，尽管他们显然是帝国主义者。但是，你知道，越南人还没准备好独立。为什么会有人想要背弃法兰西的荣耀等等？而且二战后的法国人，他们真的需要这个，对吧？他们真的需要，他们觉得他们需要恢复一些他们在二战的许多
humiliations of World War II. The really interesting thing here is that behind the scenes, the Americans in the late 40s are anti-imperialist. And they, a lot of American officials, that is. And they think that the French cause is a losing one and they don't really want to back this losing horse. And yeah, they're kind of nervous about, because Ho Chi Minh and the Viet Minh, they're nationalists, but they're also, they're communists through and through, right? They're Maoists, some of them are Stalinists, like these are not sort of warm and fuzzy, cuddly liberals. So it's a difficult choice. But a lot of US officials are thinking the French have behaved appallingly. I mean, FDR, when he trots out sort of the worst examples of European imperialism, it's always the french in indo-china that's who he singles out um that's very gratifying it is very good yeah well he also
羞辱中显然已经失去的荣耀。这里真正有趣的是，在幕后，40年代末的美国人是反帝国主义的。而且他们，很多美国官员是这样。他们认为法国的事业是注定失败的，他们并不真的想支持这匹输掉的马。而且是的，他们有点紧张，因为胡志明和越盟，他们是民族主义者，但他们也是，他们是彻头彻尾的共产主义者，对吧？他们是毛主义者，他们中有些人是斯大林主义者，这些人不是那种温暖、毛茸茸、可爱的自由派。所以这是一个艰难的选择。但许多美国官员认为法国人的行为令人震惊。我的意思是，富兰克林·罗斯福，当他列举欧洲帝国主义的最坏例子时，总是法国在印度支那，那是他特别指出的，嗯，这非常令人欣慰，确实非常好，是的，嗯，他也
he gave churchill a hard time sometimes but then he would what made churchill feel good is then fdr would turn to the french and be like oh they're they're even worse than you so what are the french doing that say worse than the belgians in the congo well i don't think they're worse than the belgians in the congo i'm not sure fdr gave much thought to the belgians in the Congo. Well, I don't think they're worse than the Belgians in the Congo. I'm not sure FDR gave much thought to the Belgians in the Congo. Right. What are the French doing that's so terrible? It's not, it's so,
他有时会让丘吉尔感到难受，但随后他会，让丘吉尔感到高兴的是，富兰克林·罗斯福会转向法国人说，哦，他们甚至比你们更糟。那么法国人做了什么比比利时人在刚果做的事情更糟？嗯，我不认为他们比比利时人在刚果更糟，我不确定富兰克林·罗斯福是否对比利时人在刚果的问题想得很多。嗯，我不认为他们比比利时人在刚果更糟。我不确定富兰克林·罗斯福是否对比利时人在刚果的问题想得很多。对。法国人做了什么那么可怕的事情？它不是，它是如此，
I mean, like with any kind of colonial history, you have a lot of episodes that happen that are, that don't exactly cover the French in glory, but it's basically France has lost the Japanese in World War II, kicked the French out. That's why it's that struggle between Japan and France that brings the U.S. into World War II because Japan wants to take over French Indochina, not because it in and of itself is important, but it's a launching pad for further expansion. And then they move into French Indochina. The U.S. knows this.
我的意思是，就像任何殖民历史一样，你有很多发生的事件，它们并不完全让法国人感到光荣，但基本上是法国在二战中输给了日本人，日本人把法国人赶走了。这就是为什么日本和法国之间的那种斗争把美国带入了二战，因为日本想要接管法属印度支那，不是因为它本身很重要，而是它是进一步扩张的发射台。然后他们进入了法属印度支那。美国知道这一点。
They start to put an embargo on Japan. And so Japan says, well, we have to go further now into the Dutch East Indies and Malaya to get all these natural resources there, especially oil. And they knock out the U.S. fleet at Pearl Harbor as a preemptive strike to stop the U.S. from preventing Japanese expansion in Southeast Asia. So the French are knocked out. They come back. They try and come back in 45, 46 when clearly they didn't have the power to do so. And like I was saying, the US behind the scenes, US officials, a lot of US officials were thinking this is a really bad idea. But at the same time, the Cold War is ramping up in Europe, and the US absolutely needs
他们开始对日本实施禁运。所以日本说，好吧，我们现在必须进一步进入荷属东印度群岛和马来亚，以获取那里的所有自然资源，特别是石油。他们摧毁了珍珠港的美国舰队，作为阻止美国防止日本在东南亚扩张的先发制人打击。所以法国人被赶走了。他们回来。他们在45、46年试图回来，当时他们显然没有能力这样做。就像我说的，美国在幕后，美国官员，很多美国官员认为这是一个非常糟糕的主意。但与此同时，冷战在欧洲加剧，美国绝对需要
France on side in Europe. And so the French essentially make them a quid pro quo offer. They say, fine, we'll support you in Europe against the Soviets if you support us against the Viet Minh in Vietnam. And that's how the US gets involved. At that point, is American anxiety about the communism of the Vietnamese freedom fighters? I mean, does that have currency? Increasingly, absolutely. Increasingly so. Not so much in 45, 46, 47. The Viet Minh and the OSS, the Office of Strategic Services, which was the forerunner of the CIA, they cooperate. Like they run joint operations together, joint missions together from southern China against the Japanese.
法国在欧洲站在自己这一边。所以法国人本质上给了他们一个交换条件。他们说，好吧，如果你们支持我们对抗越南的越盟，我们就会在欧洲支持你们对抗苏联。这就是美国卷入的方式。在那一点上，美国对越南自由战士的共产主义的焦虑吗？我的意思是，这有市场吗？越来越多，绝对是。越来越多了。在45、46、47年没那么多。越盟和战略情报局（OSS），即中情局的前身，他们合作。就像他们从中国南部针对日本人进行联合行动、联合任务一样。
Ho Chi Minh writes letters to FDR. Ho's codename was OSS Agent 19. And Ho spoke some English. I mean, they were allies against the Japanese. And then that kind of all falls apart as we get into the Cold War. And then as you said, Tom, anxiety about US anxiety about communism sort of kicks into super high gear in 1947-48. And by that point, the sides are kind of hardening on both sides. And then if we move forward a bit, obviously it goes wrong for the French. The French basically, I'm trying to remember this from sort of our last thoughts about
胡志明给富兰克林·罗斯福写信。胡的代号是OSS特工19。而且胡会说一些英语。我的意思是，他们是反对日本人的盟友。然后随着我们进入冷战，这一切都瓦解了。然后正如你所说，汤姆，美国对共产主义的焦虑在1947-48年进入了超高速档。到那时，双方的立场都在某种程度上硬化了。然后如果我们再往前走一点，显然这对法国人来说出了问题。法国人基本上，我正试图从我们上次关于
about 20 years ago. The French are basically cornered, aren't they, at Dien Bien Phu. Right. And the Americans, now I might be completely misremembering this, but don't the Americans have meetings about it? Andard nixon is vice president and nixon says would it not be a good idea to drop a nuclear bomb on them is that not right yeah i forget i actually forget if uh nick if nixon himself recommended nukes but he definitely recommended going in hard as a lot but there were other i mean the joint chiefs thought maybe we should use nukes, tactical nukes, to rescue the French garrison at Dien Bien Phu. And Eisenhower eventually decides no. And one of
大约20年前的想法中回忆这一点。法国人在奠边府基本上被逼到了墙角，不是吗？对。而美国人，现在我可能完全记错了，但美国人没有开会讨论这件事吗？尼克松是副总统，尼克松说扔一颗原子弹不是个好主意吗，那不对吗？是的，我忘了，我实际上忘了尼克松本人是否建议使用核武器，但他绝对建议强硬对待，就像很多，但还有其他人，我的意思是参谋长联席会议认为也许我们应该使用核武器，战术核武器，来营救奠边府的法国驻军。而艾森豪威尔最终决定不。而其中
the reasons he decides no is because A, he thinks it's a bad idea, but B, he asks Churchill what he thinks, Churchill's prime minister, of course, at this time. And Churchill says that's a terrible idea. I mean, as much as he's pro-French, as much as he's pro-Empire, he thought that was a bad idea. You had a very good opportunity there, which you've turned down to do, a Winston Churchill impersonation. But maybe if you warm into the podcast, you can. I think I'll have to warm into it.
他决定不的原因之一是因为A，他认为这是一个坏主意，但B，他问丘吉尔他怎么想，丘吉尔当然是当时的首相。而丘吉尔说那是个可怕的主意。我的意思是，尽管他亲法，尽管他亲帝国，但他认为那是个坏主意。你刚才有一个非常好的机会，你拒绝了，做一个温斯顿·丘吉尔的模仿。但也许如果你在播客中热身，你可以。我想我得热身一下。
American characters, I can do. British characters, I find it more difficult. But if I do one, then you have to do one of your American impressions, Tom. Oh, you know how Tom did a hilarious yee-haw. Yeah, mine was brilliant. In the wild west. It was greeted with rapturous enthusiasm on the other side of the Atlantic.
美国角色，我能做。英国角色，我觉得更难。但如果我做一个，那么你就必须做一个你的美国模仿，汤姆。哦，你知道汤姆是怎么做一个搞笑的“耶哈”的。是的，我的很棒。在狂野西部。它在大西洋彼岸受到了热烈的欢迎。
The French get captured and kind of marched off to prisoner of war camps. So that's a humiliation for European self-esteem following on the humiliation of the British against the Japanese and so on. And so that presumably is playing into the idea that white people going around and telling people around the world what to do is fading out. I know that we've described the Vietnam War as a kind of anti-imperial imperialism, but do the Americans feel that they're kind of, you know, swimming against the tide of, I mean, I suppose that they're casting that tide as a Marxist tide and therefore it obscures what's happening. Would that be fair? Exactly. Exactly. That's putting it exactly right. The US, I mean, this is the thing.
法国人被俘虏并被押送到战俘营。所以这对欧洲自尊心来说是一种羞辱，继英国人对日本人失败之后的羞辱等等。所以这大概是在影响白人到处走动并告诉世界各地的人该做什么的想法正在消退。我知道我们已经把越南战争描述为一种反帝国主义的帝国主义，但美国人是否觉得他们正在，你知道，逆流而上，我的意思是，我想他们把那股潮流描述为马克思主义潮流，因此它掩盖了正在发生的事情。这样说公平吗？完全正确。完全正确。这就是准确的说法。美国，我的意思是，这就是重点。
In retrospect, it's easy to sort of make the argument. Max Hastings makes this argument in his recent book on the Vietnam War, which is a fantastic book, that the U.S. basically – one of the big mistakes the U.S. made was just taking over the French role in Vietnam in 1954-55 and becoming a kind of, you know, if not old school 19th century scramble for Africa imperialists, they become kind of neo-imperialists or neo-colonialists or whatever. And it's easy to see that in retrospect, but Americans at the time were worried about that. And they bent over backwards to try and prevent that, which is why they wanted to build up South Vietnam as a kind of South Korea, as a Taiwan, as a West Germany, you know, all these divided countries in the Cold War, you want to use them as test cases, as laboratories for this is why our system is superior than their system. And South Vietnam was going to be that. And it wasn't, you know,
回想起来，很容易得出这个论点。马克斯·黑斯廷斯在他最近关于越南战争的书中提出了这个论点，这是一本很棒的书，即美国基本上——美国犯下的重大错误之一就是仅仅在1954-55年接管了法国在越南的角色，并成为了一种，你知道，如果不是老派19世纪瓜分非洲的帝国主义者，他们成为了一种新帝国主义者或新殖民主义者等等。回想起来很容易看到这一点，但当时的美国人对此感到担忧。他们竭尽全力试图防止这种情况，这就是为什么他们想把南越建设成一种韩国、台湾、西德，你知道，冷战中所有这些分裂的国家，你想把它们用作试验案例，作为实验室，证明为什么我们的制度比他们的制度优越。而南越就是要成为那个。而且它不是，你知道，
Americans at the time said, well, there's no way we're an empire. We're not imperialists. We don't do empire. We just defeated an empire in Nazi Germany and Japan. We're fighting an empire against the Soviet Union. We're not imperialists, even if we think they are. And they would stress the, you know, economic development and political freedom and all that sort of thing. And they wanted to build up South Vietnam as this kind of example of what could happen, what could work if people turn their back against communism. Just wondering about the ongoing role of the French in this. When the French see the Americans piling in, where they've just completely screwed up.
当时的美国人说，好吧，我们绝不是帝国。我们不是帝国主义者。我们不做帝国。我们刚刚在纳粹德国和日本击败了一个帝国。我们正在与苏联进行一场帝国主义战争。我们不是帝国主义者，即使我们认为他们是。他们会强调，你知道，经济发展和政治自由等等。他们想把南越建设成这种如果人们背弃共产主义可能发生什么、可能行得通的例子。只是想知道法国人在其中的持续作用。当法国人看到美国人涌入时，他们刚刚完全搞砸了。
So we've got a question from Michael Healy. Why did no one seem to ask the French, who had had something of a shocker in Vietnam a few years prior, whether this was a good idea, and even what lessons the French had learned from said shocker? I mean, is that fair? Are the Americans consulting the French? And what did the French think of it?
所以我们有一个来自迈克尔·希利的问题。为什么似乎没有人问法国人，他们在几年前在越南经历了一些冲击，这是否是个好主意，甚至法国人从上述冲击中学到了什么教训？我的意思是，这公平吗？美国人在咨询法国人吗？法国人对此怎么看？
It's so interesting. When you read the declassified documents, the Americans consulting the French? And what do the French think of it? It's so, when you read the declassified documents, the Americans are well aware of this. And they're saying, but we're not the French. We're not the French. We'll do it right. We'll avoid the French mistakes. We're the good guys.
这太有趣了。当你阅读解密文件时，美国人在咨询法国人吗？法国人对此怎么看？这太，当你阅读解密文件时，美国人很清楚这一点。他们说，但我们不是法国人。我们不是法国人。我们会做对的。我们会避免法国人的错误。我们是好人。
We're the good guys. But they have a low opinion of the French, obviously, because the French, I mean, they must have so much baggage of World War II, right? They think the French are shoddy performers. They'll always crack. They, you know, they can't be trusted. Cheese-eating surrender monkeys. They do think that though, don't they? I mean, they clearly do. They absolutely think that. They think we're not going to make the same mistakes as the French.
我们是好人。但他们显然对法国人评价很低，因为法国人，我的意思是，他们一定背负着二战的沉重包袱，对吧？他们认为法国人是劣质的表演者。他们总是会崩溃。他们，你知道，他们不可信。吃奶酪的投降猴子。他们确实那样想，不是吗？我的意思是，他们显然确实那样想。他们绝对那样想。他们认为我们不会犯法国人犯过的同样错误。
We're going to do it smart. We'll do it right. And we're not going to wilt. And in 1963, de Gaulle himself, I mean, this is classic de Gaulle, right? So the French leave and then they leave Algeria, you know, several years after that. And it's in 1963. So it's post Vietnam, post Algeria, if you're, if you're the French and to go then kind of has the temerity to say, um, it's a bad idea to go into these countries and to sort of impose your rule. And he tells the Americans very publicly, um, you know, you should just get out of Vietnam. We should neutralize Vietnam, meaning we should make it get, get everyone there to agree. They won't be communistists. They won't be non-communists. And we'll, all the great powers will stay out of it. And he really lectures the Americans. He really scolds them. And of
我们要聪明地做。我们会做对的。而且我们不会枯萎。而在1963年，戴高乐本人，我的意思是，这是典型的戴高乐，对吧？所以法国人离开了，然后他们在几年后离开了阿尔及利亚。而且是在1963年。所以这是越南之后，阿尔及利亚之后，如果你是法国人，戴高乐然后有点胆量说，嗯，进入这些国家并强加你的统治是个坏主意。他非常公开地告诉美国人，嗯，你知道，你们应该直接离开越南。我们应该中立化越南，意思是我们要让每个人都同意。他们不会是共产主义者。他们不会是非共产主义者。而我们，所有大国都将置身事外。他真的教训了美国人。他真的责骂了他们。当然，
course, the Americans are like rolling their eyes and they're just like, come on, you know, give me a break. But, you know, de Gaulle was right. And you could say, okay, the French made those mistakes, but then they learned from the mistakes. But the Americans said, we're not the French. So there's another obvious dimension, which is the British, right? Don't the Americans also talk to the Brits? The Brits are obviously in Malaya at the same time. The Brits are fighting insurgents in Malaya. And don't the Brits say, this is a very bad idea and you shouldn't do this?
美国人就像翻白眼，他们就像，得了吧，你知道，放过我吧。但是，你知道，戴高乐是对的。你可以说，好吧，法国人犯了那些错误，但后来他们从错误中吸取了教训。但美国人说，我们不是法国人。所以还有另一个明显的维度，那就是英国人，对吧？美国人不是也和英国人谈过吗？英国人显然同时在马来亚。英国人正在马来亚打击叛乱分子。英国人不是说，这是一个非常糟糕的主意，你们不应该这样做吗？
You should learn our lessons? Or what's the story there? Well, here's the thing. Only later do they say that in the mid to late 60s when Vietnam is clearly a bad idea. The Americans in the 1950s, so the U.S. is building up South Vietnam. The U.S. is also fighting a counterinsurgency, much smaller counterinsurgency war in the Philippines against the Hucs, who were a leftist nationalist, kind of like the Viet Minh insurgency in the Philippines. So they're helping the Filipinos fight that insurgency in the Philippines. So they're helping the Filipinos fight that insurgency. They're also assisting from, but really learning from the British in Malaya, because the British
你们应该吸取我们的教训？或者那里的故事是什么？嗯，事情是这样的。直到后来他们才那样说，在60年代中期到后期，当越南显然是个坏主意时。1950年代的美国人，所以美国正在建设南越。美国也在菲律宾打击反叛乱，规模小得多的反叛乱战争，针对胡克党，他们是左翼民族主义者，有点像菲律宾的越盟叛乱。所以他们正在帮助菲律宾人打击那场叛乱。他们也在协助，但实际上是从马来亚的英国人那里学习，因为英国人
are fighting a counterinsurgency in the 50s against Chinese communists in Malaya that works, that's successful. And it's still to this day, it's held up as how to do counterinsurgency. Look at Malaya. Don't look at Vietnam. Look at Malaya in the 1950s. And so the US thinks, because it's got all this advice from Britain, because it's kind of had this experience in the Philippines, it thinks, yeah, we can do this. We're not the French. We're learning from the British. We're taking our ideas applied in the Philippines. We can do this. We've got this. Not realizing that againstietnamese communists and nationalists they are up against like the the best most hardened most committed fighters um they just one of the
在50年代正在马来亚打击针对中国共产主义者的反叛乱，这奏效了，是成功的。而且直到今天，它仍然被视为如何进行反叛乱的典范。看看马来亚。不要看越南。看看1950年代的马来亚。所以美国认为，因为它从英国得到了所有这些建议，因为它在菲律宾有这种经验，它认为，是的，我们可以做到。我们不是法国人。我们正在向英国人学习。我们正在应用在菲律宾的想法。我们可以做到。我们能行。没有意识到，面对越南共产主义者和民族主义者，他们面对的是像最优秀、最强硬、最坚定的战士，嗯，他们只是其中之一
things is they just picked the wrong enemy in the wrong place in the wrong time could i that we've got a question from jim condi on britain and vietnam and he asked how close did the uk come to getting involved and he cites the experiences in Malaya and how much damage to the decision not to assist affect Harold Wilson's relationship with the US. Yeah, Wilson was in a really, really tough spot because LBJ put huge, Lyndon Johnson, put huge pressure on Wilson to send troops. Wilson, very, very conveniently,
的事情是他们只是在错误的时间、错误的地点选择了错误的敌人。我能，我们有一个来自吉姆·康迪关于英国和越南的问题，他问英国离卷入有多近，他引用了在马来亚的经历，以及不协助的决定对哈罗德·威尔逊与美国的关系造成了多大损害。是的，威尔逊处于一个非常、非常艰难的境地，因为林登·约翰逊，林登·约翰逊，给威尔逊施加了巨大的压力，要求他派遣军队。威尔逊，非常、非常方便地，
I mean, it was a real struck of luck. He had an out and LBJ wanted him to ignore this out, but Wilson could fall back on it. And it was that Britain and the Soviets. So in 1954, when the French are kicked out, there's a big conference in Geneva and the great powers decide against the V this – they're going to split Vietnam in two at the 17th parallel. And that's where you get North and South Vietnam. And the Viet Minh are in North Vietnam and the US kind of oversees South Vietnam. And that was supposed to be temporary, but it becomes permanent. And overseeing that arrangement to make sure everything was fair – this brings me back to Wilson – there was something – there was a commission created to oversee the partition of Vietnam and the fact that there would be free and fair elections to reunify the country two years later in 1956. And Britain and the Soviet Union are made the kind of co-conveners of that commission
我的意思是，这真是运气好。他有一个退路，而林登·约翰逊想让他忽略这个退路，但威尔逊可以依靠它。那就是英国和苏联。所以1954年，当法国人被赶走时，日内瓦举行了一次大型会议，大国决定反对越南——他们要在北纬17度线将越南一分为二。这就是你得到北越和南越的地方。越盟在北越，而美国某种程度上监管南越。那本应该是暂时的，但它变成了永久的。而监管那个安排以确保一切公平——这让我想起了威尔逊——有一些东西——建立了一个委员会来监管越南的分裂，以及两年后在1956年会有自由公正的选举来统一国家的事实。而英国和苏联被任命为那个委员会的共同召集人
to oversee what goes on in Vietnam. And that commission is technically still around in the 60s. Even though it has no power, nobody listens to it. And so when Johnson puts all this pressure on Wilson to send troops, Wilson says, you know, I'd love to, but I can't. Damn. I can't. I've got this commission that requires me to be objective. You know, I'd love to send troops. It's all these scenes, aren't there, where LBJ says, just send me a band.
来监管越南发生的事情。而那个委员会在60年代技术上仍然存在。尽管它没有权力，没人听它的。所以当约翰逊给威尔逊施加所有压力要求派遣军队时，威尔逊说，你知道，我很想，但我不能。该死。我不能。我有这个委员会要求我保持客观。你知道，我很想派遣军队。有所有这些场景，不是吗，约翰逊说，只要给我一支乐队。
Just send me a marching band or something so that I can tell people the British are involved. And Will always weasels out of it. Well, I'm not going to – that's up for you. But the Australians, they sign up. So you do get cricket pitches as well as baseball pitches. That's right. I get in my mention of cricket.
只要给我一支行进乐队什么的，这样我就可以告诉人们英国参与了。而威尔逊总是想方设法逃避。嗯，我不会——那是你的事。但澳大利亚人，他们报名了。所以你确实得到了板球场以及棒球场。没错。我提到了板球。
So this goes back to a question that Dom or something Dom raised at the beginning about misconceptions. I mean, we think that the whole world was against American involvement in Vietnam. And most of it was. And pretty much all of Europe was. And Canada was. And a good chunk of the U.S. itself was. Latin America was. Most former colonial
所以这回到了多姆或多姆在开始时提出的关于误解的问题。我的意思是，我们认为全世界都反对美国卷入越南。大部分确实是。几乎整个欧洲都是。加拿大也是。美国本身很大一部分也是。拉丁美洲也是。大多数前殖民
countries were but the countries in southeast asia in the region volunteer a lot of them most of them voluntarily sent troops um australia new zealand taiwan south korea the philippines thailand um you know they were they were kind of scared of a communist advance as well it doesn't mean that it made it right, intervention right in Vietnam, because to me, it clearly wasn't right. But it is complex. And there was an Australian journalist who was asked by an American anti-war protester. It's a great quote from the war that is probably like most of the best quotes from the Vietnam War, completely apocryphal. But it's such a good quote that I use it all the time in teaching.
国家也是，但东南亚地区的国家，该地区的国家自愿，他们中的大多数，自愿派遣了军队，嗯，澳大利亚、新西兰、台湾、韩国、菲律宾、泰国，嗯，你知道，他们也害怕共产主义的推进。这并不意味着它使干预正确，在越南的干预，因为对我来说，它显然是不正确的。但它很复杂。有一位澳大利亚记者被一位美国反战抗议者问到。这是战争中一句很棒的引语，可能像越南战争中大多数最好的引语一样，完全是伪造的。但它是一句如此好的引语，以至于我在教学中一直使用它。
And the American war protester asked the Australian journalist, why are you sending troops to this clearly unjustifiable, illegitimate war? And the Aussie is reported to have said, to you Americans, it's the Far East, but to us in Australia, it's the Near North. I mean, this is our backyard. So sometimes it's a little more complex than we think. But Andrew, that raises a really interesting question. So obviously, anybody of our generation or later came to the study of this with this baggage, with this sense, you know, it was a complete disaster and it was a legitimate war and the Americans dropped all this napalm and they
而那位美国战争抗议者问澳大利亚记者，为什么你们要派遣军队参加这场显然不可辩解、非法的战争？据报道，那位澳大利亚人说，对你们美国人来说，这是远东，但对我们澳大利亚人来说，这是近北。我的意思是，这是我们的后院。所以有时它比我们想象的要复杂一点。但安德鲁，这提出了一个非常有趣的问题。所以显然，我们这一代或以后的人在研究这个问题时都带着这种包袱，带着这种感觉，你知道，这是一场彻底的灾难，这是一场非法的战争，美国人投下了所有这些凝固汽油弹，他们
destroyed, you know, cities and killed lots of innocent people and all this it's very hard to rid yourself of that but um there is a surely a question i mean the british succeeded in malaya and they you know malaysia exists right i mean the state that they basically created exists similarly with south korea the americans intervene in south in korea they created a sort of korean south Vietnam that worked, that's still very successful. And that, you know, people don't see that now as illegitimate or even though that was an incredibly bloody and horrible war. So had it succeeded, we wouldn't think the same way about the Vietnam War, would we? I mean, if it had worked, then people wouldn't see it as imperialist and illegitimate. Would they or would they? No, it really cuts right to the core, right to the heart of one of the most difficult things about the Vietnam War.
摧毁了，你知道，城市并杀死了许多无辜的人，所有这些，很难摆脱这一点，但嗯，肯定有一个问题，我的意思是，英国人在马来亚成功了，他们（你知道，马来西亚存在，对吧？我的意思是，他们基本上创建的国家存在），同样对于韩国，美国人干预了韩国，他们创建了一种韩国式的南越，那是行得通的，现在仍然非常成功。而且，你知道，人们现在并不认为那是不合法的，即使那是一场极其血腥和可怕的战争。所以如果它成功了，我们就不会以同样的方式看待越南战争了，对吧？我的意思是，如果它奏效了，那么人们就不会认为它是帝国主义和非法的。他们会吗，还是不会？不，它真的直击核心，直击越南战争最困难的事情之一。
So the U.S., I still think that the war was illegitimate and I still think that it was unnecessary. I always have. And my view on that hasn't really changed. And when you look at what actually happened, as you were saying, the U.S. dropped almost four times the bomb tonnage on Indochina, on Vietnam, Laos and Cambodia. Almost four times. It's like over three and a half times. Then it dropped. Then all parties dropped in all of World War II. I mean, that's incredible.
所以美国，我仍然认为那场战争是不合法的，我仍然认为它是没必要的。我一直这么认为。我对这一点的看法并没有真正改变。当你看看实际发生了什么，正如你所说，美国在印度支那，在越南、老挝和柬埔寨投下的炸弹吨位几乎是四倍。几乎是四倍。它就像超过三倍半。然后它投下了。然后所有各方在整个二战中投下的。我的意思是，那太不可思议了。
It's incredible. I mean, it just defies logic. And Laos is the most heavily bombed per capita. It's the most heavily bombed country in the world. Here's a really weird thing. Of all those bombs that the U.S. dropped, more than everyone did in World War II, in all theaters of World War II,
太不可思议了。我的意思是，它简直违背逻辑。而老挝是人均被轰炸最严重的。它是世界上被轰炸最严重的国家。这里有一件非常奇怪的事情。在所有那些美国投下的炸弹中，比二战中每个人投下的都多，在二战的所有战区中，
not just the U.S. bombs, not just U.S. bombs, but every country that fought World War II, the U.S. dropped more bombs in Vietnam and Laos and Cambodia than in all of World War II. That in itself is staggering. But then when you think about that, of the bombs that the U.S. dropped more bombs in Vietnam and Laos and Cambodia than in all of World War II. That in itself is staggering. But then when you think about that, of the bombs that the U.S. dropped in Indochina in the 1960s and 70s, it bombed its ally, South Vietnam, more than it bombed anyone else. I mean, the majority of the bombs that the U.S. dropped were on its ally, South Vietnam.
不仅仅是美国的炸弹，不仅仅是美国的炸弹，而是每一个参加二战的国家。美国在越南、老挝和柬埔寨投下的炸弹比整个二战期间还要多。这本身就令人震惊。但当你想到这一点时，美国在20世纪60年代和70年代在印度支那投下的炸弹中，它轰炸其盟友南越的次数比轰炸任何其他地方都要多。我的意思是，美国投下的大部分炸弹都落在了它的盟友南越身上。
I mean, that speaks to the difficulty of war. Can I ask a really dumb question? Why are they doing that? Well, that's where the war is. That's where the insurgency is. Right. Okay. No, to the difficulty really dumb question why are they doing that well that's where the that's where the war is that's where the insurgency is right okay um no it's not it's not a dumb question it again it gets right to the this this bizarre war this sort of illogical war but going back to to dom's question um the korean war was just as bloody i mean proportionally it was bloodier than if you sort of it was only three years long the actual fighting so if you adjust it for the for the amount of time they spot fighting,
我的意思是，这说明了战争的艰巨性。我能问一个非常愚蠢的问题吗？他们为什么要那样做？嗯，因为战争就在那里。叛乱就在那里。对。好的。不，关于战争的艰巨性，这是一个非常愚蠢的问题，他们为什么要那样做，嗯，因为战争就在那里，叛乱就在那里。对，好的。嗯，不，这不是一个愚蠢的问题，它再次直指这场离奇的战争，这种不合逻辑的战争。但回到多姆的问题，嗯，朝鲜战争同样血腥，我的意思是，按比例来说，它比越南战争更血腥。如果算上实际战斗时间，它只持续了三年，所以如果你根据他们实际战斗的时间来调整，
there was more destruction, more death in Korea than there was in Vietnam. It was a brutal, awful war and it was unpopular at home. And that's why Harry Truman didn't run again for president was because Korea was so unpopular. And yet it turned out to be a success story. And so it raises this question that I love to discuss with my students. Is the result what determines morality? I mean, sometimes it doesn't clearly. Sometimes things are just wrong. I still think the Vietnam War was wrong, but when you look at Korea, where the reasons for intervention were the same as they were in Vietnam, the scale of the brutality, the use of napalm, the indiscriminate bombing of civilian targets, civilian populations, all that kind of stuff. It's the same as in Vietnam. I mean, it's basically the same war with key differences, of course, but in essence, it's the same war.
朝鲜战争造成的破坏和死亡比越南战争更多。那是一场残酷、可怕的战争，在国内也不受欢迎。这就是哈里·杜鲁门没有竞选连任总统的原因，因为朝鲜战争太不受欢迎了。然而，它最终却成了一个成功的故事。所以这提出了一个我喜欢和学生讨论的问题：结果是否决定了道德？我的意思是，有时结果并不能清楚地说明问题。有时事情就是错误的。我仍然认为越南战争是错误的，但当你看看朝鲜，干预的原因和越南一样，残酷的程度、凝固汽油弹的使用、对平民目标和平民人口的无差别轰炸，所有这些事情。这和越南是一样的。我的意思是，这基本上是同一场战争，当然有关键的区别，但本质上，它是同一场战争。
And yet nobody would want to sort of go back and undo the Korean War now, right, when you look at South Korea and North Korea. I mean, it's the scale of the mismatch. It's the David and Goliath that I guess is kind of a key part of the fascination of it and um maybe we could look at the kind of you know the the way that american public opinion responded to it and the politics of it in the second half um and we should have a break but just just to end with um a question from vriendman who asks is vietcong the most badass army of the Yes. Okay.
然而，现在没有人会想回到过去撤销朝鲜战争，对吧，当你看看韩国和朝鲜时。我的意思是，这是双方实力悬殊的程度。大卫与歌利亚的较量，我想这是它令人着迷的一个关键部分，嗯，也许我们可以看看美国公众舆论对它的反应以及下半场的政治，我们应该休息一下，但最后以维恩德曼的一个问题结束，他问越共是不是最强悍的军队？是的。好的。
Well, on that note, the most badass army of the second half of the 20th century. We'll go to a break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just
好吧，说到这一点，20世纪下半叶最强悍的军队。我们要休息一下。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚
launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, Dominic Sandbrook here. I've loved history since I was a boy. I grew up reading swashbuckling stories about adventures and battles, from the courage of the few as they soared above the Channel to the terror of Anne Boleyn on her way to the scaffold. A couple of years ago, I tried to find something similar for my own son,
推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，我是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。我从小就热爱历史。我读着关于冒险和战斗的侠义故事长大，从少数人在海峡上空翱翔的勇气，到安妮·博林在前往断头台路上的恐惧。几年前，我试图为我自己的儿子寻找类似的书，
a rollicking narrative history of the Second World War, but none of the bookshops had quite what I wanted. So in the end, I decided to write it myself. And not just one book, but a series. Adventures in Time, published by Penguin. The first two books, about the Second World War and the six wives of Henry VIII, are out now. They've got exciting stories and great characters, just as you'd expect from a children's book. As my son puts it, it's fun, but it's history. Adventures in Time are available now for children from 8 to 80. So that's Adventures in Time by me, Dominic Sandbro. And if they don't satisfy, you know where to go for a refund. His name is Tom Holland.
一本关于第二次世界大战的生动叙事历史，但没有一家书店有我想要的。所以最后，我决定自己写。不仅是一本书，而是一个系列。《时间冒险》，由企鹅出版社出版。前两本书，关于第二次世界大战和亨利八世的六个妻子，现在已经出版了。它们有激动人心的故事和伟大的人物，正如你对儿童读物所期望的那样。正如我儿子所说，它很有趣，但它是历史。《时间冒险》现在可供8岁到80岁的孩子阅读。这就是我多米尼克·桑德布鲁克写的《时间冒险》。如果它们不能让你满意，你知道去哪里退款。他的名字叫汤姆·霍兰德。
Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are in Vietnam with Professor Andrew Preston from Cambridge University, and he's talking us through the war. Andrew, so this is a question that has always puzzled me. I mean, you probably remember a book that came out when we were PhD students together, Michael Lynn's book, Vietnam, The Necessary War. Oh, yeah. And this was a sort of revisionist account of the war that said it was the right war to fight and America bought time for its allies and all this kind of thing. So thinking about difficult questions about the war and sort of revisionist questions, here's one.
欢迎回到《剩下的就是历史》。我们正在越南，与剑桥大学的安德鲁·普雷斯顿教授在一起，他正在为我们讲解这场战争。安德鲁，这是一个一直困扰我的问题。我的意思是，你可能记得我们一起读博士时出版的一本书，迈克尔·林恩的书《越南：必要的战争》。哦，是的。这是一种修正主义的战争叙述，说这是一场正确的战争，美国为盟友争取了时间等等。所以，考虑到关于战争的难题和修正主义问题，这里有一个。
Could the US have won it?ist questions, here's one. Could the US have won it? I mean, couldn't they? They had so much military hardware. Is there a case that a sort of right wing revisionist American historians say that they were stabbed in the back by public opinion? And that basically, this was always the general's case, right? The general said, if you just give us more time, if you let us use more firepower, we will bomb them back to the Stone Age. I mean, that was their expression. Could that have happened or was that just a fantasy? So I think it's I think it's a fantasy. I don't think they I don't think they could have won the war. The generals were saying that, but not at first in 63, 64, 65, when LBJ is because the big war, the big American war begins in the spring and summer of 1965. And Johnson is then asking everyone, the CIA, Joint Chiefs of Staff, State Department, everyone, what should we do? And they have these, I mean, you know this, Dom, you've looked at this stuff too.
美国能赢吗？修正主义问题，这里有一个。美国能赢吗？我的意思是，他们不能吗？他们有那么多的军事装备。是否有这样一种情况，即右翼修正主义美国历史学家说他们被公众舆论从背后捅了一刀？这基本上一直是将军们的观点，对吧？将军们说，如果你再给我们一点时间，如果你让我们使用更多的火力，我们会把他们炸回石器时代。我的意思是，那是他们的表达方式。这可能发生吗，还是那只是一个幻想？所以我认为这是一个幻想。我不认为他们能赢得这场战争。将军们当时是那么说的，但不是在63、64、65年刚开始的时候，当时大战争，即美国的大规模战争在1965年的春夏开始。约翰逊当时在问每个人，中央情报局、参谋长联席会议、国务院，每个人，我们该怎么办？他们有这些，我的意思是，你知道这一点，多姆，你也看过这些东西。
They have these endless series of meetings. And the people who are least keen on going to war, on having a big war in 1965, there are some people in the state department, you'd suspect that, um, or you'd expect that. Um, but the joint chiefs are really, I don't think you could call them anti-war because then you're picturing these sort of four-star generals burning bras and wearing long hair and sort of marching with pickets. It's not that, but they told LBJ, this is this war. If so, they say, if we're going to win this war, if we're going to win this war, it's going to take more than half a million men. It's going to take many, many years. It's going to take a really long commitment. You have to know what you're getting into. And even then, our chances of winning aren't great. I mean, so they were super realistic. It's not like- So they absolutely know what they're getting into. cautious about Iraq in 2003, but it's not like Iraq 2003, where you have people like Bush and Rumsfeld thinking, this is going to be a cakewalk. This is going to be easy. Nobody thought that about Vietnam. Once they're in, then the generals are like, okay, if we're in, we're going to win.
他们有没完没了的会议。而在1965年最不愿意参战、不愿意打大仗的人中，国务院里有一些人，你会怀疑这一点，或者你会预料到这一点。嗯，但参谋长联席会议成员，我不认为你可以称他们为反战人士，因为那样你就会想象这些四星上将烧掉胸罩、留着长发、举着标语牌游行。不是那样的，但他们告诉LBJ，这是这场战争。如果，他们说，如果我们想赢得这场战争，如果我们想赢得这场战争，它将需要超过50万人的兵力。它将需要很多很多年。它将需要一个非常长期的承诺。你必须知道你卷入了什么。即使那样，我们获胜的机会也不大。我的意思是，所以他们非常现实。这不像——所以他们完全知道自己卷入了什么。对2003年的伊拉克很谨慎，但这不像2003年的伊拉克，当时有布什和拉姆斯菲尔德这样的人认为，这将是一场轻而易举的胜利。这将很容易。没有人那样看待越南。一旦他们进去了，那么将军们就会说，好吧，如果我们进去了，我们就会赢。
It's hard to believe, at least for me, it's hard to believe to think that the US, which helped defeat Nazi Germany and Imperial Japan, the US is the U.S. is the only party in World War II that fought a truly global war. Britain did as well, but the U.S. to a much greater extent. That took a lot of doing, right? And so it's hard to believe that they couldn't then defeat not just Vietnam, but just North Vietnam, half of the part of Vietnam that didn't really ever industrialize and was very, very poor. But what it would have taken, it would have taken bombing them back to the Stone Age. It would have taken making, to use another expression from the time, making North Vietnam a parking lot.
很难相信，至少对我来说，很难相信美国，那个帮助击败了纳粹德国和日本帝国的国家，美国是二战中唯一参与了真正全球战争的一方。英国也参与了，但美国参与的程度要大得多。这需要付出很多努力，对吧？所以很难相信他们不能击败不仅仅是越南，而是北越，越南的一半，那个从未真正工业化且非常非常贫穷的部分。但如果真的要做到，就需要把他们炸回石器时代。就需要，用当时的一句表达，把北越变成一个停车场。
And, you know, you have to ask, is that worth it? Is it feasible? What do you do with the country afterwards? So winning in absolute terms, yeah, the US probably could have done that. But winning on any kind of acceptable terms, even by the US's own standards of why they were fighting the war, no, I don't think it was possible. So a question for both of you, because I know that you both have very informed opinions on this, from Jack Hennison about LBJ. Is Lyndon Johnson's legacy unfairly tarnished due to his escalation of the Vietnam War as his
而且，你知道，你必须问，这值得吗？这可行吗？之后你拿这个国家怎么办？所以从绝对意义上讲，是的，美国可能做到了。但在任何可接受的条件下获胜，即使按照美国自己参战的标准，不，我不认为这是可能的。所以有一个给你们俩的问题，因为我知道你们俩对此都有非常知情的意见，来自杰克·亨尼森关于LBJ的问题。林登·约翰逊的遗产是否因为他在越南战争中的升级而受到了不公正的玷污，因为他的
domestic policies were largely successful in his lifetime and I see I don't know if you saw last week there was a report on the narcissism of US presidents saying that the more narcissistic they were the likely they were to go to war and LBJ was the most narcissistic of them all so what do you think that's pretty much i think i well i think he was the most he i think he was the most narcissistic i think he was the most insecure but i did read that story as well tom i think it was in the times at least i read it in the times and i haven't read the full article but i was immediately skeptical because lbj did not want to go to war and if he could have made vietnam disappear as a problem he would have he and he didn't want to go to war. And if he could have made Vietnam disappear as a problem, he would have. And he didn't want to go to war. And this gets to your question or the question that was
国内政策在他有生之年基本上是成功的。我不知道你上周是否看到了，有一份关于美国总统自恋程度的报告，说他们越自恋，就越有可能发动战争，而LBJ是其中最自恋的一个，所以你们怎么看？我想，嗯，我认为他是最，我认为他是最自恋的，我认为他是最缺乏安全感的，但我确实读过那个故事，汤姆，我想是在《泰晤士报》上，至少我在《泰晤士报》上读过，我没有读过全文，但我立刻持怀疑态度，因为LBJ不想参战，如果他能让越南问题消失，他会那样做的，他不想参战。如果他能让越南问题消失，他会那样做的。而且他不想参战。这涉及到你的问题或刚才被问到的问题。
just asked. He didn't want to go to war because he worried that the war would then overshadow his great society. It would overshadow civil rights reforms. It would overshadow and undermine and maybe eventually ruin this incredible domestic reform program that he had. Andrew, let me jump in there. Your mate, or our mate, Fred Logevill has a book called Choosing War, where he argues that it was, you know, the common, he says it's a common misconception that it was Kennedy's fault, that Kennedy, that it was Lyndon Johnson deliberately chose war,
他不想参战，因为他担心战争会掩盖他的“伟大社会”计划。它会掩盖民权改革。它会掩盖、破坏并最终可能毁掉他拥有的这个令人难以置信的国内改革计划。安德鲁，让我插一句。你的朋友，或者我们的朋友，弗雷德·洛格瓦尔有一本书叫《选择战争》，他在书中认为，你知道，普遍的误解是这是肯尼迪的错，是肯尼迪，是林登·约翰逊故意选择了战争，
he argues, partly because he was insecure, because he wanted to show his Cold War kind of cojones, because he felt the kind of Kennedy legacy hanging over him. And Johnson deliberately did it. And you say that you don't buy that. This is a family podcast. You can say cojones on here. Tom Holland talks about eunuchs and the genital mutilation we've had on this. And I didn't think we'd be getting it into this podcast, but yet again. But we have. That's what editors are for. As it were, pulled it off. No, Fred's absolutely right. This is a book called Choosing War. It's one of my favorite books on the war. It changed my whole, it came out when I was doing
他认为，部分原因是由于他缺乏安全感，因为他想展示他在冷战中的那种“胆量”，因为他感到肯尼迪的遗产笼罩着他。约翰逊是故意这样做的。而你说你不买账。这是一个家庭播客。你可以在这里说“胆量”。汤姆·霍兰德谈论过太监和我们所经历的生殖器切割。我没想到我们会在这期播客中谈到这个，但我们又谈到了。但我们确实谈到了。这就是编辑的作用。正如人们所说，成功了。不，弗雷德完全正确。这是一本名为《选择战争》的书。这是我关于战争的最喜欢的书之一。它改变了我整个，它是在我做
my PhD, as Dom said, it changed my whole thinking on the war and the course of my PhD. So I think it's a great book. And I agree with Fred that LBJ chose war, that there were alternatives. That's the basic. Because one of the longstanding arguments about the war is that it's unfair to criticize Kennedy and especially Johnson for getting the US into Vietnam because they inherited this long commitment. It was the Cold War. And criticizing them for getting involved is sort of using hindsight. Hindsight's 20-20. We realize it's a mistake now, but going back to the early and mid-60s, it's unfair to criticize them of not knowing that it would become a disaster. But they knew, like I was saying about the Joint Chiefs. I mean, they knew. LBJ knew that it was going to be, at the very, very least, it was going to be extremely difficult. And he ultimately chose war. And maybe it's because he was insecure. Maybe it's even because he was narcissistic. But my point is that he, there was no rush to war. He deliberated for almost two years as to whether to go to war. And he kept looking for an out. And eventually he went to war because he felt backed into a corner, painted into a corner. And maybe that was because of domestic politics. Maybe that was because he was insecure about his
博士时出版的，正如多姆所说，它改变了我对战争的整个看法以及我博士研究的过程。所以我认为这是一本好书。我同意弗雷德的观点，即LBJ选择了战争，是有替代方案的。这是基本的。因为关于战争的长期争论之一是，批评肯尼迪，尤其是约翰逊让美国卷入越南是不公平的，因为他们继承了这个长期的承诺。那是冷战。批评他们卷入其中有点事后诸葛亮。事后诸葛亮总是对的。我们现在意识到这是一个错误，但回到60年代初和中期，批评他们不知道这会变成一场灾难是不公平的。但他们知道，就像我刚才说的关于参谋长联席会议。我的意思是，他们知道。LBJ知道这将是，至少，这将是非常困难的。他最终选择了战争。也许是因为他缺乏安全感。也许甚至是因为他自恋。但我的观点是，他，并没有急于开战。他权衡了近两年是否要开战。他一直在寻找出路。最终他开战了，因为他感到被逼到了墙角，被困在了墙角。也许是因为国内政治。也许是因为他对自己
manhood or whatever. So he did choose war. But I don't know, a narcissist like Trump or somebody else to me seems pretty keen and pretty eager to sort of pull the trigger if he wants to pull the trigger. And Johnson was absolutely reluctant. I do think, I mean, it has tarnished his legacy, hasn't it? Absolutely. It's totally tarnished turned and it in some ways it's a great legacy civil rights immigration reform um not quite universal health care but universal health care for old people and poor people and so so the context for um lbj's presidency and then everything that follows is um escalating anti-war protests and we've got a number of questions on that so we've got one from um two listeners who regularly contribute great questions we've got
的男子气概缺乏安全感等等。所以他确实选择了战争。但我不知道，像特朗普或其他什么人那样的自恋者对我来说似乎很热衷，很渴望在想扣动扳机时扣动扳机。而约翰逊绝对是勉强的。我确实认为，我的意思是，这玷污了他的遗产，不是吗？绝对是。它完全玷污了，在某些方面这是一个伟大的遗产，民权、移民改革，嗯，虽然不是全民医疗保健，但为老年人和穷人提供了全民医疗保健。所以LBJ总统任期以及随后发生的一切的背景是，嗯，不断升级的反战抗议，我们收到了很多关于这方面的问题，所以我们有一个来自，嗯，两位经常贡献好问题的听众，我们有
diego morgado who asks was the anti-war movement in the us driven by university educated middle class kids who just didn't want to go to war or was it more politically deep and widespread than that and we've got one from chet Archbold, who also Canadian, I think. How broad was the anti-war sentiment by the late 60s and early 70s? Was it a majority view or just a vocal minority? And to what degree was it a product
迭戈·莫加多，他问：美国的反战运动是由那些只是不想参战的受过大学教育的中产阶级孩子推动的，还是它在政治上比那更深刻、更广泛？我们还有一个来自切特·阿奇博尔德的问题，我想他也是加拿大人。到60年代末和70年代初，反战情绪有多广泛？它是多数人的观点，还是仅仅是一个大声疾呼的少数派？它在多大程度上是那个十年中美国文化发生巨大变化的产物
or a cause of the great sea change in American culture during that decade? And I know that both of you will have so much to say on that that we could be here for hours. So just very short answers from both of you. I think in answer to the first question, it was both.
或原因？我知道你们俩对此会有很多话要说，我们可能会在这里待上几个小时。所以你们俩只给简短的回答。我认为回答第一个问题，两者皆有。
It was both a principled stand and it was both people didn't want to go fight this very difficult to explain war, a war that was being fought in very tough circumstances, under very tough conditions, for reasons that a lot of people just thought were immoral and illegitimate. And of course, the people who were protesting were the ones who would have had to go fight that war. And so they had a stake in it, right? They definitely weren't. They had an interest in it. There was a conflict there. Because we should explain to listeners that the US had a draft. Had a draft, that's right.
这既是一个原则性的立场，也是因为人们不想去打这场非常难以解释的战争，一场在非常艰难的环境下、在非常艰苦的条件下进行的战争，其原因很多人只是认为是不道德和非法的。当然，抗议的人正是那些不得不去打那场战争的人。所以他们与此有利害关系，对吧？他们绝对不是。他们对此有利益冲突。因为我们应该向听众解释，美国有征兵制。有征兵制，没错。
Your number was drawn and then you had to go, right? Unless you like Donald Trump, didn't he have a dodgy foot or something? Well, yeah, he had bone spurs. Or at least he got a doctor to say he had bone spurs. Yeah, a lot of powerfully connected people got out of the draft that way. And there were other ways you could get out of it. What's that? Bill Clinton.
你的号码被抽中了，然后你就得去，对吧？除非你像唐纳德·特朗普，他不是有什么脚部问题还是什么的吗？嗯，是的，他有骨刺。或者至少他找了个医生说他有骨刺。是的，很多有权势的人就是那样逃避征兵的。还有其他方法可以逃避。是什么？比尔·克林顿。
Well, Bill Clinton, he didn't come up with a kind of dodgy medical reason and then go party at Studio 54 and avoiding STDs, which Donald Trump says was his Vietnam. Bill Clinton actually wrote – it says a lot about American politics. Bill Clinton wrote a sort of anguished letter saying why he didn't want to fight. He was in Oxford at the time, I think, when he wrote this letter saying why he didn't want to fight. And he was in Oxford at the time, I think, when he wrote this letter saying why he didn't want to fight. So, you know, there are a lot of bad things we could say about Bill Clinton, but, you know, he kind of took a principled stand. Just to go back to the first question that you asked, Tom, about, you know, what was the, is this really just middle-class protest or is there something deeper to it? One of my favorite stories that I tell my students
嗯，比尔·克林顿，他没有编造某种可疑的医疗理由，然后去54号摄影棚聚会，避免性病，唐纳德·特朗普说那是他的越南。比尔·克林顿实际上写了一封信——这说明了很多关于美国政治的事情。比尔·克林顿写了一封痛苦的信，说明他为什么不想参战。我想他当时在牛津，当他写这封信说明他为什么不想参战时。所以，你知道，关于比尔·克林顿我们可以说很多坏话，但，你知道，他算是采取了一个原则性的立场。回到你问的第一个问题，汤姆，关于，你知道，什么是，这真的只是中产阶级的抗议，还是有更深层的东西？我告诉学生的最喜欢的故事之一
is from a Time Magazine reporter covering the riots in Chicago, the anti-war riots in Chicago in 1968. A riot that wasn't caused by the students, but was caused by the police, the Chicago PD. There was a wonderful movie last year called the one with Sacha Baron Cohen. Yeah.
来自《时代》杂志的一名记者，他报道了1968年芝加哥的骚乱，反战骚乱。那场骚乱不是由学生引起的，而是由警察，芝加哥警察局引起的。去年有一部很棒的电影，叫那个有萨莎·拜伦·科恩的电影。是的。
The Trial of the Chicago 7, isn't it? That's it, The Trial of the Chicago 7. Fantastic movie, really, really good movie. And it and it's historically i mean it plays fast and loose sometimes to tell a good story but it's a really it's a really good movie i've seen it seen it several times there was a time magazine reporter who was covering the riots this basically where the chicago pd declared war on these protesters and again it's it's it's almost too good this quote is almost too good it must be apocryphal but it was reported so i'm going to go with it um and it's where too good. This quote is almost too good. It must be apocryphal, but it was reported.
《芝加哥七君子审判》，对吧？就是那个，《芝加哥七君子审判》。很棒的电影，真的，真的很好的电影。而且它在历史上，我的意思是，它有时为了讲好故事而不太严谨，但它确实是一部非常好的电影，我看过好几次。当时有一名《时代》杂志的记者在报道骚乱，基本上是芝加哥警察局向这些抗议者宣战，而且再次，它几乎太好了，这个引语几乎太好了，它一定是伪造的，但它被报道了，所以我打算用它，嗯，它太好了。这个引语几乎太好了。它一定是伪造的，但它被报道了。
So I'm going to go with it. And it's where a policeman was beating a protester, this kid, this university kid, and beating him with his nightstick, his billy club. And as the cop raises his club to sort of land the final blow, the student raises his fist and yells, long live the proletariat. And the cop says, I am the proletariat and the cop says i am the proletariat and then proceeds to beat him senseless now it gets at this another one of these fundamental contradictions in in the war and the protest movement that um it's been called a working class war because most of the draftees who went off to fight it were working class who supported the war the protesters were mostly university age mostly middle class there is that social dynamic and that social dynamic
所以我打算用它。当时一名警察正在殴打一名抗议者，这个孩子，这个大学生，用他的警棍，他的短棍殴打他。当警察举起棍子准备给予最后一击时，学生举起拳头大喊：“无产阶级万岁！”警察说：“我就是无产阶级！”然后继续把他打得不省人事。现在，这触及了战争和抗议运动中另一个基本矛盾，即它被称为一场工人阶级的战争，因为大多数去参战的应征入伍者都是支持战争的工人阶级，而抗议者大多是大学生，大多是中产阶级。存在那种社会动态，而那种社会动态
i don't think i'm sort of drawing too neat a line from the 60s to the present that's the same that's the exact same dynamic we see through american politics right up to today with donald trump and conservative populace i completely buy that i mean the phrase the silent majority yeah comes from this period. Richard Nixon gives this speech talking about, I'm appealing to you, the great silent majority. And this is the period in which Nixon is posed wearing a hard hat. I mean, very George Osborne-ish now, but at the time, because men, building workers in hard hats had attacked in New York City, I think 1970. 1970, that's right. A demonstration of precisely that kind of, you know, middle class affluent kids with long hair. But the kids with long hair were right, though. That's what I would like to add to that,
我不认为我是在从60年代到今天画一条太整齐的线，那正是我们在美国政治中看到的完全相同的动态，一直到今天，唐纳德·特朗普和保守派民粹主义者。我完全同意这一点，我的意思是，“沉默的大多数”这个词，是的，来自这个时期。理查德·尼克松发表了这篇演讲，谈到，我呼吁你们，伟大的沉默的大多数。这是尼克松戴着安全帽摆姿势的时期。我的意思是，现在看起来很像乔治·奥斯本，但在当时，因为男人，戴着安全帽的建筑工人在纽约市袭击了，我想是1970年。1970年，没错。一场正是那种，你知道，留着长发的富裕中产阶级孩子的示威。但留长发的孩子是对的，虽然。这就是我想补充的，
about the war. Another question, further complicating the dynamics of this from Adrian RP, can you comment on the racial makeup of US soldiers in relation to Muhammad Ali's comments that America was sending black boys to kill their brothers? Yeah. So African-American troops were drafted at twice out of proportion to their makeup of the US military personnel. And then they made up around a quarter of casualties. So they're about 10 percent, 12 percent of the population. They end up making about 25 percent of the casualties in Vietnam.
关于战争。另一个问题，进一步复杂化了这一点，来自阿德里安·RP，你能评论一下美国士兵的种族构成，以及穆罕默德·阿里关于美国正在派遣黑人男孩去杀害他们的兄弟的评论吗？是的。所以非裔美国士兵被征召入伍的比例是他们在美国军事人员中所占比例的两倍。然后他们占了伤亡人数的四分之一左右。所以他们大约占人口的10%到12%。他们最终占了越南伤亡人数的25%左右。
I mean, just that basic figure kind of should give you pause. Paul Hardcastle's, I think, 1984, 85 hit, which basically consisted of him talking about the average age of new combat soldiers in Vietnam. He says in World War II, the average age of the combat soldier was 26. In Vietnam, he was 19. No, no, no, no, 19. Is that true?
我的意思是，仅仅这个基本数字就应该让你停下来思考。保罗·哈德卡斯特1984年或85年的热门歌曲，基本上由他谈论越南新战斗士兵的平均年龄组成。他说在二战中，战斗士兵的平均年龄是26岁。在越南，他是19岁。不，不，不，不，19岁。那是真的吗？
Pass. Pass. You don't know. Paul Hardcastle got it right. I don't know. Who knows? What about fragging? Who knows?
不知道。不知道。你不知道。保罗·哈德卡斯特说对了。我不知道。谁知道呢？那“碎裂”（fragging）呢？谁知道呢？
Andrew is fragging, Andrew? Is fragging a myth that particularly black soldiers would, you know, would they rig a grenade to kill their officers? Is that right? It's not a myth. It happened. I don't know about the ratio. I don't know if it was predominantly blacks on whites or anything like that.
安德鲁，什么是“碎裂”？“碎裂”是一个神话吗，特别是黑人士兵会，你知道，他们会设置手榴弹来杀死他们的军官吗？那是真的吗？这不是神话。它确实发生了。我不知道比例。我不知道这是否主要是黑人对白人，或者类似的事情。
But it was, yeah, if you're in the last years of the war, Nixon ended the draft. And all of a sudden, not coincidentally, you see protests start to decline. He also began to withdraw U.S. troops. You know, it's like John Kerry said to Congress when he was a student. This is in 1973 or something, or 72. And he was testifying to Congress and he said, how do you ask a man to be the last man to die for a mistake? So in the last few years of the war, drug use goes up.
但确实，是的，如果你在战争的最后几年，尼克松结束了征兵。突然之间，并非巧合，你看到抗议活动开始减少。他还开始撤出美国军队。你知道，就像约翰·克里在学生时代对国会说的那样。这是在1973年左右，或者72年。他在国会作证时说，你怎么能要求一个人成为最后一个为一个错误而死的人？所以在战争的最后几年，毒品使用量上升了。
There are incidents of fragging against officers. And you would, I mean, come on, if you're sitting there and you're in your base and you can hear a firefight and then a sergeant or a lieutenant jumps up and says, right, let's go fight those commies. And you're like, you know, and the US is clearly on the way out of the war. Yeah.
发生了针对军官的“碎裂”事件。而且你会，我的意思是，拜托，如果你坐在那里，你在基地里，你可以听到交火声，然后一个中士或中尉跳起来说，好吧，让我们去打那些共产主义者。而你会，你知道，而且美国显然正在撤出战争。是的。
I mean, you're not going to be up for it. Here's a quick question for you before we go. We need to talk about popular culture. I imagine Tom wants to talk about films. I do. But just before you do that, you mentioned Nixon. I did. So Nixon at the time and afterwards has got an incredibly bad press
我的意思是，你不会有那种心情。在我们要走之前，这里有一个快速问题。我们需要谈谈流行文化。我想汤姆想谈谈电影。我确实想。但在你谈论之前，你提到了尼克松。我确实提到了。所以尼克松在当时和之后都受到了极其糟糕的媒体评价
for continuing the war from January 69 when he becomes president to 1973. I've always wondered about that because I've always thought it was almost, it was impossible for Nixon to just cut, you know, he couldn't, as it were, cut and run. I mean, the US has made this massive commitment to South Vietnam and he was kind of stuck at that stage. Am I being too kind to Nixon, do you think? It's a leading question because Dom, I know you're a fan of Richard Nixon and you used to teach a very popular course when you were a university lecturer on Nixon. I think there's something, so I know the answer you want me to give. Yeah, give my answer, please. I don't think I can. I don't think I can give the Dom Sandberg answer. But I think there's
因为他从69年1月他成为总统到1973年一直在继续战争。我一直对这一点感到好奇，因为我一直认为这几乎是，尼克松不可能只是切断，你知道，他不能，正如人们所说，切断并逃跑。我的意思是，美国已经对南越做出了巨大的承诺，他在那个阶段被困住了。你认为我对尼克松太仁慈了吗？这是一个引导性问题，因为多姆，我知道你是理查德·尼克松的粉丝，当你担任大学讲师时，你曾经教授一门关于尼克松的非常受欢迎的课程。我想有某种，所以我知道你想要我给出的答案。是的，请给出我的答案。我不认为我可以。我不认为我能给出多姆·桑德布鲁克的答案。但我认为有
something, I think there is something to it. It's a poison chalice withdrawing from Vietnam. Do you just, as the expression was, do you just turn tail and run? I mean, Nixon thought you shouldn't because it would damage American credibility. And I'm sure that's true, although I think that Nixon and Henry Kissinger exaggerated the extent to which people you're leaving behind? And when the US eventually did leave in 73, and then when the whole thing was then all over in 75, you know, there was a bloodbath of the people who were anti-communist and a lot of them were Roman Catholic and they didn't want communism. These are South Vietnamese. And, you know, they were treated really, really, really harshly.
某种，我认为确实有某种道理。从越南撤军是一个毒杯。你只是，正如那句表达所说，你只是夹着尾巴逃跑吗？我的意思是，尼克松认为你不应该，因为这会损害美国的信誉。我相信那是真的，尽管我认为尼克松和亨利·基辛格夸大了你留下来的人的程度？当美国最终在73年离开，然后在75年一切都结束时，你知道，那些反共的人经历了一场大屠杀，他们中的许多人是罗马天主教徒，他们不想要共产主义。这些是南越人。而且，你知道，他们受到了非常、非常、非常严厉的对待。
And you could, you know, if you're South Vietnamese in 1975, 76, you're thinking, hold on a second. The Americans can go home, but what do we do? And a lot of people in Afghanistan are thinking that now. I still think it was right for the US to leave Vietnam. I think it's right, actually, that it's right for the US to leave Afghanistan as well. But it comes at a huge, huge, huge cost. Dominic allowed me to do a podcast on Nero. So I think I've got to allow him to do a podcast on Nixon at some point. So just moving away from Nixon, because two further, which I think are interconnected. So we've got a question from Sneaks McCoy. Why did the US military allow
而且你可以，你知道，如果你是1975年、76年的南越人，你会想，等一下。美国人可以回家，但我们怎么办？现在很多阿富汗人也在这样想。我仍然认为美国离开越南是正确的。我实际上认为美国离开阿富汗也是正确的。但它付出了巨大、巨大、巨大的代价。多米尼克允许我做一个关于尼禄的播客。所以我认为我必须在某个时候允许他做一个关于尼克松的播客。所以只是离开尼克松，因为还有两个，我认为是相互关联的。所以我们有一个来自Sneaks McCoy的问题。为什么美国军方允许
journalists such unrestricted and unprecedented access to military actions during the vietnam war what were they hoping to gain so this is this is a war that is massively people know about it it's it's a huge deal it's in people's television sets around the world um and then we had a lot of questions about um why has vietnam been such such a focus for popular culture i mentioned mentioned Paul Harcastle's song, but obviously films particularly. And then as a finishing question for this episode, I think Blocky McBlock faces, which film is the most accurate portrayal of it?
记者在越南战争期间对军事行动进行如此不受限制和前所未有的访问？他们希望获得什么？所以这是一场战争，人们对此有大量的了解，这是一件大事，它出现在世界各地人们的电视机里，嗯，然后我们收到了很多关于，嗯，为什么越南一直是流行文化的焦点？我提到了保罗·哈德卡斯特的歌，但显然电影尤其如此。然后作为这一集的结束问题，我想Blocky McBlock faces问，哪部电影是对它最准确的描绘？
But Sneaks' question first about, why did the US allow journalists the access that they did? I mean, it's going back to the, I guess the discussion about photos that we began with. Yeah. And also that, yeah, we didn't really finish that. We only came up, I think, with three photos. And there are a couple, I think, that are missing of sort of iconic images that we might get to. It's a great question because, of course, a lot of press coverage was critical to the war or critical about the war. Most of it wasn't though. That's another
但先回答Sneaks关于，为什么美国允许记者进行他们所做的访问的问题？我的意思是，这回到了，我猜是我们开始时关于照片的讨论。是的。而且，是的，我们并没有真正完成那个讨论。我想我们只提出了三张照片。而且我认为有几张标志性的图像缺失了，我们可能会谈到。这是一个很好的问题，因为当然，很多新闻报道对战争是批判性的，或者对战争持批评态度。虽然大部分不是。那是另一个
misconception that we have. Dom mentioned stab in the back before, but there was no stab in the back because the press until very, very, very late, the American press was on side with the war. And if it was critical, it was only simply because they were reporting what was actually going on. And they were reporting what was actually going on, which contradicted the official line, because to go back to your questioner, US troops had almost unfettered access to the war. They could hop on a helicopter or on a truck or a Jeep or whatever and go cover the fighting right where it was and then send a dispatch to Hong Kong to a bureau in Hong Kong. And it would get to The New York Times or L.A. Times right away. And that would contradict the official line. So the question is, why did the US government allow these journalists to do that? Which they've since learned from, right? In the Iraq War, in the Gulf War, reporters are embedded with the
我们有的误解。多姆之前提到了“背后捅刀”，但没有“背后捅刀”，因为媒体直到非常、非常、非常晚的时候，美国媒体都是站在战争一边的。如果它是批判性的，那仅仅是因为他们报道了实际发生的事情。他们报道了实际发生的事情，这与官方路线相矛盾，因为回到你的提问者，美国军队对战争几乎有不受限制的访问权。他们可以跳上一架直升机或一辆卡车或一辆吉普车或任何东西，去报道战斗发生的地方，然后发送一份电报到香港，到香港的一个分社。它会立即传到《纽约时报》或《洛杉矶时报》。那将与官方路线相矛盾。所以问题是，为什么美国政府允许这些记者这样做？他们后来从中吸取了教训，对吧？在伊拉克战争中，在海湾战争中，记者被嵌入到
military control very tightly. One reason is because there was no declaration of war. So officially at the time, the thinking was, we can't really impose a lot of restrictions on the press because there isn't a declaration of war legally. How can we do this? How can we start clamping down on the press if we're not officially technically at war? After Vietnam, the Pentagon and the White House aren't so squeamish about legalities like that. But at the time, that was one reason. And then officially, the U.S. is there at the invitation of the South Vietnamese government. And the South Vietnamese never imposed
军队中，控制非常严格。一个原因是当时没有宣战。所以当时官方的想法是，我们不能真的对媒体施加很多限制，因为没有宣战。我们怎么能这样做？如果我们不是正式地、技术上处于战争状态，我们怎么能开始压制媒体？越南之后，五角大楼和白宫对那样的法律问题就不那么拘谨了。但在当时，那是原因之一。而且官方上，美国是在南越政府的邀请下在那里的。而南越从未实施过
censorship. And so the reporters can go off and just cover the war. And you get your David Halberstams and your Neil Sheehan and your Malcolm Browns, these really famous reporters who were initially very pro-war in the early 60s. They wanted to see
审查。所以记者们可以去报道战争。你有了你的大卫·哈伯斯塔姆、尼尔·希恩和马尔科姆·布朗，这些非常著名的记者，他们在60年代初最初是非常支持战争的。他们想看到
South Vietnam not go communist. And then they start covering the war. And they see that, A, there are all these lies that are being told about the war, but also just that it's not going well and that it's probably unwinnable at any acceptable cost. And that's what they start reporting. So what are the two photos? So we've mentioned, what have we had? We've had the embassy.
南越不变成共产主义。然后他们开始报道战争。他们看到，A，关于战争有各种各样的谎言，但也看到它进展不顺利，而且它可能在任何可接受的成本下都是无法获胜的。这就是他们开始报道的内容。那么那两张照片是什么？所以我们提到了，我们有什么？我们有大使馆。
We had the embassy. And we've got the monk burning himself. So what are the other two? Well, I mean, you could mention a number, but probably the one that my students often mention first, it would either be Kim Phuc, the girl, or the Buddhist monk, but is the South Vietnamese colonel shooting a young Viet Cong in the head. That's a shocking image, right?
我们有大使馆。我们有僧侣自焚。那么另外两张是什么？嗯，我的意思是，你可以提到很多，但可能我的学生经常首先提到的那一张，要么是金福，那个女孩，要么是佛教僧侣，但那是南越上校向一名年轻的越共头部开枪。那是一张令人震惊的图像，对吧？
It's an incredibly shocking image. And actually nowadays where we have to be more careful about what we teach because of student reactions and a lot of those images are, I generally don't believe in things like trigger warnings and whatnot, but I do give a kind of trigger warning. I give a trigger warning for a lot of these photos because they are really, really upsetting and that's a really upsetting one. But at the time, that photo, so you see Nguyen Ngoc Loan, the colonel, putting the gun to the young – because he's a kid in a flannel shirt, shorts.
那是一张令人难以置信的令人震惊的图像。而且实际上现在我们必须更加小心我们教什么，因为学生的反应，很多那些图像是，我通常不相信像触发警告之类的东西，但我确实给了一种触发警告。我给很多这些照片提供了触发警告，因为它们真的，真的令人不安，而那是一张非常令人不安的照片。但在当时，那张照片，所以你看到阮玉鸾，那位上校，把枪对准那个年轻人——因为他是一个穿着法兰绒衬衫、短裤的孩子。
He's wearing flip-flops. He's probably like 16 or 17. And he's just – maybe he's 20. And he's just shot. And the photo is really shocking. And the photographer who took it, a guy named Eddie Adams, who won a Pulitzer Prize for it,
他穿着人字拖。他可能大约16或17岁。而他只是——也许他20岁。而他只是被枪杀了。那张照片真的令人震惊。拍摄它的摄影师，一个叫埃迪·亚当斯的人，他因此获得了普利策奖，
was traumatized by what he saw. And he felt complicit, right? Because your photo, he didn't do anything to stop it, even though he didn't do the shooting. The shooting happened because they knew a photographer was there. So they wanted to make a point,
被他所看到的创伤了。他感到同谋，对吧？因为你的照片，他没有做任何事情来阻止它，尽管他没有开枪。枪击发生是因为他们知道有摄影师在那里。所以他们想表达一个观点，
the South Vietnamese troops during the Tet Offensive. And so they call Eddie Adams over and the camera crew. And it happens. And so it's incredibly traumatising it's an incredibly powerful photo it was also televised and shown on the news, on a lot of news broadcasts
南越军队在春节攻势期间。所以他们叫埃迪·亚当斯过来，还有摄像组。然后它就发生了。所以它令人难以置信地创伤，它是一张令人难以置信地强大的照片，它也被电视转播并在新闻中播出，在很多新闻广播中
and you see the guy I don't even think you can watch it on YouTube now you see the guy flinch as the bullet you see him flinch, you see him fall to the ground, you see blood, it's really really awful. Okay. And the fifth,
你看到那个人，我甚至不认为你现在能在YouTube上看到它，你看到那个人在子弹射出时畏缩，你看到他畏缩，你看到他倒在地上，你看到血，它真的真的太可怕了。好的。第五张，
the fifth photo, would there be one? There's kind of iconic images of, of GIs and helmets, aren't there? Kind of looking, there's iconic ones of GIs with the helmets. And yeah,
第五张照片，会有吗？有那种戴头盔的美国大兵的标志性图像，不是吗？那种，有戴头盔的美国大兵的标志性图像。是的，
exactly. Iconic one was GIs with a thousand yard stare. Yeah. Larry Burrows, Don McCullen, photographers like that took a lot of those. Just to go back to that last photo, am I not right in thinking the kid, though? There's a twist, which is the kid had killed somebody just before it was taken or something like that. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
完全正确。标志性的是有“千码凝视”的美国大兵。是的。拉里·伯罗斯、唐·麦卡林，像那样的摄影师拍了很多那样的照片。回到最后那张照片，我没记错的话，那个孩子？有一个转折，就是那个孩子在照片拍摄前刚刚杀了一个人还是什么的。是的，是的，是的。
That this was revenge rather than the kid wasn't being, you know, randomly. The kid had just killed somebody or something. Yeah, yeah. This isn't a war. This is in the midst of a war. War is hell. War is hell. War is hell.
这是复仇，而不是那个孩子被，你知道，随机地。那个孩子刚刚杀了一个人还是什么的。是的，是的。这不是一场战争。这是在战争之中。战争就是地狱。战争就是地狱。战争就是地狱。
To go back to helmets. So back to Blockface's question, which I think should be our last question. Which film is the most accurate portrayal of it? Actually, let's diversify that. Which is the best? Which is the most accurate because i'm guessing they're not the same different questions right yeah i don't know if there is an
回到头盔。所以回到Blockface的问题，我认为这应该是我们的最后一个问题。哪部电影是对它最准确的描绘？实际上，让我们多样化一下。哪部是最好的？哪部是最准确的，因为我猜它们不是同一个问题，对吧？是的，我不知道是否有。
accurate i don't know if there is an accurate film um about but how do you make an accurate film about something that's complicated and confusing as as any war actually absolutely and also how do you make it how can how can i judge it how can i judge its accuracy not that i wasn't alive in the 60s and didn't see the fighting, but I've never been in combat. I've never, I don't know what accurate is or isn't. Okay, the best, the best. I do know that a lot of the films, a lot of the American films aren't accurate. And we know that, I don't know what's accurate, but we know what's inaccurate.
准确，我不知道是否有一部关于它的准确电影，但你如何能为像任何战争一样复杂和令人困惑的事情制作一部准确的电影呢？当然，而且你如何制作它，我怎么能评判它，我怎么能评判它的准确性呢？并不是说我没有经历过60年代，也没有见过战斗，但我从未上过战场。我从来不知道什么是准确的，什么是不准确的。好吧，最好的，最好的。我确实知道很多电影，很多美国电影并不准确。我们知道这一点，我不知道什么是准确的，但我们知道什么是不准确的。
But a lot of those films are great films. And even if they travel in kind of stereotypes and this and that. So Apocalypse Now, I still think as problematic as it is, it's an extremely problematic film. But Apocalypse Now is still, it's just an incredible film. Do you know, that's how I prepared for this podcast. I watched the director's cut. Oh, but do you think?
但其中许多电影都是伟大的电影。即使它们充斥着各种刻板印象等等。所以《现代启示录》，我仍然认为它虽然有问题，但它是一部极具争议的电影。但《现代启示录》仍然是一部令人难以置信的电影。你知道吗，这就是我为这期播客做的准备。我看了导演剪辑版。哦，但你是这么认为的吗？
Yeah, the director's cut's too long. It's much too long. No, because we fell asleep. We woke up and everyone was talking French. Oh, yeah. There was that French plantation scene, isn't there? Which he threw in. Andrew, what about The Deer Hunter?
是的，导演剪辑版太长了。太长了。不，因为我们睡着了。我们醒来时，每个人都在说法语。哦，是的。有那个法国种植园的场景，不是吗？他把它加进去了。安德鲁，《猎鹿人》怎么样？
See, I think The Deer Hunter is a much, it's a slightly forgotten film now. It's not as fashionable as Apocalypse Now, but I love, I don't know if you've seen The Deer Hunter, Tom. Robert De Niro, isn't it? You know, they have the amazing stuff in, I think, is it Pennsylvania? And the Russian roulette.
你看，我认为《猎鹿人》是一部现在被稍微遗忘的电影。它不像《现代启示录》那样时髦，但我喜欢，我不知道你是否看过《猎鹿人》，汤姆。罗伯特·德尼罗主演的，对吧？你知道，他们有很棒的内容，我想，是在宾夕法尼亚州吗？还有俄罗斯轮盘赌。
Pennsylvania, yeah. So you get this sense of the working class community. Robert De Niro isn't it you know they have the amazing stuff in I think is it Pennsylvania and the Russian roulette Pennsylvania yeah so you get this sense of the working class community I think the Ukrainians in Pennsylvania and they go off and then they come
宾夕法尼亚州，是的。所以你对工人阶级社区有了这种感觉。罗伯特·德尼罗主演的，对吧，你知道他们有很棒的内容，我想，是在宾夕法尼亚州吗？还有俄罗斯轮盘赌。宾夕法尼亚州，是的。所以你对工人阶级社区有了这种感觉，我想是宾夕法尼亚州的乌克兰人，他们出发了，然后他们回来
back at the end so you get it's not just you know Vietnam it's also a film about America and about blue collar America
最后回来了，所以你明白了，这不仅仅是关于越南，它也是一部关于美国和蓝领美国的电影。
that first hour and a bit hour and a half of the deer hunter is the best far and away the best part of the movie that takes place in Pennsylvania. It's amazing.
《猎鹿人》的前一个多小时，一个半小时，是这部电影中遥遥领先的最好部分，发生在宾夕法尼亚州。太棒了。
The second half, I loved it when I was a boy because it's a war film and it's got the Russian roulette scene and it's intense and everything. But it's just, you know, it's filmed in, I think it's filmed in Thailand. They're speaking Thai. The whole thing is ludicrous. Obviously, nothing like that happened during the war. Some of the things, though, now we realize, like, so one of the one of the famous scenes from apocalypse now maybe i hope you hadn't fallen asleep by this point tom because it's a pretty loud scene but the charlie don't surf yeah of course the rise of the valkyries but the thing yeah but right before that when he when they when um
下半部分，我小时候很喜欢，因为它是一部战争片，有俄罗斯轮盘赌的场景，而且很紧张等等。但它只是，你知道，它是在泰国拍摄的，我想。他们说的是泰语。整件事都很荒谬。显然，战争期间没有发生过这样的事情。不过，现在我们意识到，比如《现代启示录》中著名的场景之一，我希望你当时没有睡着，汤姆，因为那是一个非常吵闹的场景，但“查理不冲浪”，是的，当然还有《女武神的骑行》，但在那之前，当他，当他们，当……
colonel kilgore gets them to start surfing and there's a battle going on that might be a little over the top but gi's love to surf in v Vietnam when they weren't on duty and that's how they got their relaxation they set up the China Beach Surf Club in Danang and the Aussies I guess were the Aussies the Aussies the Aussies had they were based further south but they all had their own surf clubs and here's the thing Charlie meaning the Viet Cong Charlie Charlie may have surfed because there is some evidence where the Viet Cong would steal surfboards and use them to get around in the waterlands of the Mekong Delta and stuff like that.
基尔戈上校让他们开始冲浪，而战斗正在进行，这可能有点夸张，但美国大兵在不执勤时喜欢在越南冲浪，这就是他们放松的方式。他们在岘港建立了中国海滩冲浪俱乐部，澳大利亚人，我想是澳大利亚人，澳大利亚人，澳大利亚人，他们的基地在更南边，但他们都有自己的冲浪俱乐部。这就是重点，查理，意思是越共，查理，查理可能冲浪过，因为有一些证据表明越共会偷冲浪板，并用它们在湄公河三角洲的水域中穿行，诸如此类。
That's a great film. That's a great film. It is a great idea for a film and the perfect note on which to end this podcast. Charlie does surf. You heard it here. Andrew, can't thank you enough. Thanks, guys. Thanks. I had such a great time.
那是一部伟大的电影。那是一部伟大的电影。这是一个很棒的电影构思，也是结束这期播客的完美音符。查理确实冲浪。你在这里听到了。安德鲁，非常感谢你。谢谢，伙计们。谢谢。我玩得很开心。
It's been more than a tour of duty. Thanks so much. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这不仅仅是一次服役。非常感谢。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。如需收听奖励剧集、抢先体验、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。